as a human being what he and his wife
Kimberly suffered is heartbreaking and I
have so much sadness in my heart for
them and I my prayers are with them but
you know this is when it's really hard
is that as a judge I have to judge the
dance I know on dance with the Stars we
show their stories and lately we get to
know them and they become family and
their pain is my pain but at the same
time it's like in the Olympics like if
something happens to somebody before
they get on the gymnastics mat it
doesn't matter what happens in your
personal life I have to judge what's
happening on the dance floor and in my
opinion I have happiness who I believe
was a better dancer and had come further
it was it was hard I will say though and
my hearts are with it I can't watch I am
in your position having to do that I was
in imagine but good what you were
supposed to do I went home and I vomited
oh no no I mean that's that's where you
have to draw the line I know a lot of
people were saying that he should have
been home with his wife because she had
a miscarriage can I just say that it
just tells you what kind of a guy he is
he's a follow-through person he's a
finisher and we all go through we all go
through heartbreaking things in life but
you guys don't just say I'm not showing
up for work today I mean people have to
finish what they were doing this is a
huge competition and I admire him I
think it shows his work ethic I think it
sometimes too you have to remember that
those endorphins help you cope and so I
think we shouldn't judge him at all and
hopefully hopefully let's not judge
that's not just the judge right yeah yes
like just a joke and that's not judge
his decision for doing what he thought
was right for his family because last
night james van der beek said the little
soul we had expected to welcome into our
family took a shortcut to whatever lies
beyond and we are praying for his family
[Applause]
[Music]